we welcome you back to cbs mornings we
mentioned earlier that britain's
farewell to queen elizabeth has shifted
from scotland to london huge crowds as
you've seen are gathering to watch
today's procession that will bring the
queen's coffin from buckingham palace to
westminster hall where she will now lie
in state heathrow airport is even
delaying flights so planes do not
disturb the procession joining us now
from london is historian wesley kerr he
knows everything he's a former royal
correspondent with our partners at the
bbc good morning wesley kerr it's always
good to see you
but let's talk about this procession
we're going to see the procession move
through central london then we will see
the coffin lie in westminster abbey you
know i saw reports of people wesley
waiting over prepare to wait prepared to
wait over 20 hours just to be there just
to see this what is the significance of
this
good morning gail this is a very very
solemn and incredibly significant day
here in london in a way it's it's the
first part of the state funeral
her majesty has been spending her last
night in buckingham palace where so many
of the great events of her reign
have taken place she first appeared on
the balcony here in 1927.
she was on the balcony here the day that
the second world war ended
i've been watching her on the balcony
here and doing things in these parks
ceremonials since 1981 the day that
charles and diana married
but this this this is the most solemn
ceremonial but at the heart of it you
will see the family um
and they will have to grieve their
mother again in front of hundreds of
thousands of people
so there will be a very astonishing
procession which will leave in shortly
under two hours
and at the head of the procession will
will be her majesty um the royal
standard on the coffin and on the on on
a gun carriage and on the coffin will be
the imperial state crown which she wore
the day she was crowned her orb and her
scepter the the symbols of her majesty
and there will be i mean it will be a
very impressive but very solemn
procession which will last precisely 38
minutes it will go along the ceremonial
route of the mao
across horse guards parade where
trooping of the color takes place
then down white tall the heart of
british government past darning street
to this astonishing 11th century hall
westminster hall
her majesty was i think the 41st monarch
since william the conqueror westminster
hall was built by william the
conqueror's son and i think was for many
years the biggest room in england so
it's this astonishing place
um where charles the first trial was
where winston churchill lay in state
where both of the queensland state and
there hasn't been a state funeral since
churchill's funeral in 1965 and there
hasn't been a ceremonial procession
which we'll be seeing today since the
one that i witnessed in 2002 for her
majesty's late mother and of course
behind behind the coffin will be the
king
her majesty's other children
grandchildren most the royal family i
mean
cannons incredibly powerful moment
but wesley this is what struck me the
fact that people men women children say
if i have to wait over 20 years at 20
hours rather that's okay i had a friend
of mine i was talking to him last night
he said listen i love my mother very
much but i wouldn't wait 20 hours to see
is to stand in line to see my mother not
making light of it yeah but i'm curious
about what is it about her that the
people are willing to do this
i mean they did it for her coronation as
well so there is something about about
the monarchy and the it's an institution
that holds the country together but this
is the end of a remarkable era and it's
a remarkable lady i absolutely made a
point in downtime yesterday evening of
going to see her coffin she it was
driven past my birthplace it came
through my neighborhood and there were
several hundreds of us just in that
location
um this this is a chance personally to
say goodbye either in that way or of
course people are going to
to wait for a day or so to see and it's
actually amazing camaraderie we had
camaraderie for two hours waiting
yesterday but there's a powerful sense
of forgiveness there are people from all
over the world people have flown in from
new zealand from angola from canada just
just this week for this occasion
and they reminisce often they're
ex-service people but but
elizabeth ii
was an astonishingly popular and
successful moment
monarch and we all feel a sense of
personal connection on the way here i
went to her birthplace and just said a
prayer
um just a very powerful moment today
yeah i can only imagine i'm i'm really
very touched by all the pomp and
circumstance of the moment wesley curry
thank you i'll be flying to london this
weekend so i look forward to meeting you
in person we will have lots to discuss
we will show you the procession of the
queen's coffin from buckingham palace to
westminster hall in a cbs news special
report it starts at nine o'clock eastern